what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with Red Hood and
The Outlaws rebirth again this is pretty
cool this this deals with the whole idea
of like bizarro Superman basically
becoming a genius now if you guys
haven't seen if you guys aren't really
sure like where we where we got into
this the last video is really the only
thing you need so I'll have the last
video in the description so you guys can
be caught up but it is cool I mean you
know a little bit of an explanation here
basically bizarro has always been like
the dumb Superman but he's always
talking in like broken English or you
know done everything backwards and all
that kind of get stuff he's kind of like
the the dumb opposite version well I
guess the opposite version is Superman
cuz Superman is pretty smart so he's
like the opposite version of him but the
cool thing about this is is kind of
rolling bizarro over into DC rebirth
again the nature of DC rebirth was to
kind of shift things up in a lot of
different ways that with bizarro
it's experimenting by basically having
an put in a circumstance where his body
was essentially shutting down because he
was an experiment that wasn't supposed
to exist again all that is in the in the
previous video and then Lex Luthor
basically cured him and when he did he
set him on the path he was supposed to
be which was this perfect clone of
Superman but initially this kind of
picks up with Professor Pig now again we
talked about professor pig in our
Nightwing video he's basically just kind
of like a small-time criminal but the
guy makes his bones why just kind of
like warping and distorting the minds of
people and then turning them into his
slaves it's kind of like brainwashing
him different things like that
ultimately he was defeated and you know
again I think this I deliver exactly
where this lies in the chronology I'd
have to look it up either it takes place
before or after I mean professor Pig was
caught and arrested because you know
because of the actions of Nightwing or
maybe he got away
Donovan brought some i and it doesn't
really matter the fact remains here that
it's basically Red Hood and Artemis
responding to the event now again one
thing to bear in mind is they're largely
operating in Gotham City and so because
of that it's one of those things where
Batman just kind of gives them a license
to do their own thing and that's the
basis of Red Hood and The Outlaws
rebirth and so because of this when they
show up what we end up finding out as a
professor pigs forces were there to
essentially like steal a whole bunch of
money for the penguin and when if anyone
shows up he's like hey thanks Red Hood
I'm glad you did ask you I wanna he's
like oh but I am though but like I am
gonna take your money like it belongs to
me now later man and then just bails
which is pretty funny
it's antihero stuff and so of course
winds up having is when the cops show up
you know Red Hood and Artemis basically
take off and they go back and they meet
with bizarro now what we end up finding
out is that while they were gone what
bizarro had basically done was
completely re-engineer and reorganized
the entire basis of operate
for the Red Hood to make it like this
uber super technologically advanced
place and it's awesome because he did
this all while they were out there
that's the intelligence of bazzara is
he's basically looked around and said
well I'm essentially Superman right now
like I have the intelligence of Superman
maybe a little bit more because of what
Lex Luthor gave me and I have all the
abilities of Superman but why not put
those to a functional use it's basically
him moving things in a direction to
where they can more efficiently protect
the city of Gotham and not really have
to worry about all these major issues
the other cool thing that he that he did
here is he created like a hologram
projection of himself so that when
anybody shows up in the you know in
their base of operations if they don't
know what's going on don't think it's
him and so it it's kind of funny you
know it is it is kind of interesting
here but the fact remains he spilled all
kinds of arms and armament all this
stuff you basically had the entire bat
armory in this vessel that Bizarros been
working on and the other cool thing is
that what he has are these doors these
trains these translocation doors
basically The Doors that teleport you to
other locations each door leads to a
particular place and so with this in
mind what you end up doing is putting
the outlaws team in a place where they
can essentially access anywhere
instantaneously that they can make
awesome city a better place that's the
ultimate goal here the downside of this
is that after showing Red Hood and
everybody everything now showing Red
Hood and Artemis all this stuff and
sitting down and having this kind of
conversation with himself the responses
like this can't last forever I also want
to point out that he's wearing Crocs but
but you know he says like this this
won't last forever and that's a sad
thing see this is what so what's so
great about this and so crushing about
this like when I look at something like
bizarro Superman who's become a genius I
love the idea but we know it's not gonna
last because bizarro is known as the
goofy and nonsensical Superman you know
the the dumb one that's his identity and
so unless DC is going to implement a
paradigm shift on how bizarro functions
from now until the end of time he's
gonna go back to being the version that
he was before because of that it is kind
of cool you know when it comes to this
whole bizarro situation but what he's
also drawn is the attention of the bat
family and that's why things are
interesting because they're starting to
ask questions what are they doing why do
they basically have a vessel floating
over the city of Gotham like when was
this even here because it wasn't there
before but Saul just built it all of a
sudden and so it's like how do we not
know this is being built are we that
ineffective as a team and so it is kind
of funny because what ends up happening
is that as they go and they try to
investigate and they try to figure out
what's going on they get a message and
the message basically says you're
probably wondering what in the world's
going on right now but what's going on
right
now is that Gotham City like you guys
are not able to affect change in Gotham
City because if you had Gotham City
wouldn't be as crappy as it is right now
and so because of the fact that Gotham
City is still crappy despite the fact
the guys are trying to help fix it it
means you guys are actually fixing
anything and so we're going to fix it
for you you guys aren't necessary
anymore and this is kind of cool
because again this is one of the things
I always like asking about Gotham City
if Batman was that great of a superhero
why does Gotham City still suck that's
like it's like the coolest question to
ask why is it still garbage like you
would think that man we're just kind of
sit down and realize okay so I guess I'm
not that great of a superhero because
the city sucks just as much now as it
did when I first became Batman so maybe
somebody else should take over that's
kind of my stance on the character of
Batman loved Batman loved watching them
beat people up but it's always a
question that I always wondered but the
other thing is that with that with
bizarro himself he begins to kind of
experiment at experience like these
small little relapses here and there
this is the cool thing about the bat
family he experiences these small little
relapses here in there where he starts
to speak back in a broken English so on
and so forth and then as he starts to
punch the floor the floor is made out of
mud and so when you switch back over to
Red Hood and Artemis what are the things
that's going on is that they're kind of
having like these small little questions
that are going on to their mind you
can't help but raise an eyebrow and you
can't help but ask a question is is
there an end to this and if there is an
end to this what happens when it ends
will it end well or will it end
violently how is this going to know
houses going to conclude it's almost one
of those things were like it seems too
good to be true that's the kind of
attitude that they're adopting now they
really have that discussion later on you
know and a really really cool one-shot
following this but it is an interesting
idea because from there they basically
pick up on clay and that's when Jason
Todd's immediate response is like you
know his immediate response is basically
Clayface was here if Clayface was here
the bat family was here if the bat
family was here they largely would they
probably went after tooth or probably
went after you know bizarre and so what
is up happening is they go through and
they come across the hologram projection
of his arm assuming he's basically taken
off and when they do he's just kind of
like well I mean you know there's all
these doors here he's bound to be behind
one of them best of luck to you and then
you have like you have Red Hood and
Artemis who show up now again this is
the bat family versus the bat family
this does not take place during the bat
family Civil War this takes place I
would say probably about a couple story
arcs before that but still it you know
in this little situation it really is a
battle of loyalties but it's really
Scott Liddell's way of basically saying
like this is how the Baths family sees
red hunter that's one thing to keep in
mind if those are guys who were new to
the
Batman mythos you have the bat family
and then you have red hood red hoods
part of it but not part of it at the
same time is he's associated with the
bat family but he's really not he just
kind of goes off and does his own thing
99% of the time it's only when you have
like a massive event like the trial of
that woman the death of Clayface this
start of the Bat family civil war that
you see him roll over into Detective
Comics by and large Detective Comics is
Azrael it's bat woman Batgirl orphan
spoiler and and battling and that's
basically yet and then Red Hood may or
may not be that well I guess used to be
Clayface but not anymore and then of
course Batman himself but like that's it
and it is cool because what this kind of
indicates is that for all their their
Pramod circumstance for all their grand
jurors saying we're creating a unified
front in Gotham City the bat family
doesn't really see Jason Todd as a
full-on member of their ranks he's just
kind of an occasional guy who's there
even then even if he was it really still
is a legitimate conflict because it's
basically him sitting down there saying
Bizarros part of our team we're doing
this to protect the city of Gotham
whether you agree with it or not is
irrelevant the point is we're protecting
the city better than you guys ever did
because you know the city still stuck
still sucks and so you know as they go
through and they start fighting the
various members of the bat family it's
exactly we would expect it to be but
then you have bizarro who basically
jumps in and just starts going against
all these different members of the Bat
family now one thing to bear in mind
here is that the classic battle Batman
vs Superman who would actually win it's
always contextual that argument much
like this fight here is always
contextual because Batman's the you know
I would say he's probably the second
smartest man in the world behind Lex
Luthor and then like you have you know
Superman with all those strengths and
abilities and so on and so forth in that
situation you know I hate to bring up
prep time because I hate prep time I
feel like it's a lazy answer to the
question of how would Batman beat
Superman and I always feel like people
who use prep time just kind of do it as
like a like they're just kind of goofing
off it'll actually mean it but still
like in this scenario you go through
here and it's like okay the bad family
has to train for like the worst
circumstance
right that's the nature of the Batman
the bad family trains for like the worst
possible circumstance they train for
like the end of the world they train for
all the villains rising up against them
at the same time they train for you know
Superman showing up in Gotham and trying
to conquer it that's the point I mean
how effective would they be as a
superhero team if they trained for like
only three bad circumstances like I mean
they wouldn't be they would be very
effective because it would be any one of
the new
the other limitless circumstances that
could bring Gotham City crashing down
around and so when you're talking about
a team that was designed to take out
some very heavy hitters including
Superman Bizarros really no different
and the cool thing about this is bat
woman basically pops a lawsuit
into his mouth or pops a lozenge into
his mouth when he's screaming and it's
designed to convert the lung the the air
in his lungs to silicone which
essentially suffocates him for a
temporary amount of time and shuts him
down
bizarro basically collapses you know in
the aftermath of all this you have
Artemis in Red Hood who are kind of
going off and taking out what's left of
the bat family and then from there the
question is what do we do with bizarro
because when you're the Baths family and
this is one of the interesting things
here there are people I was looking at
reviews for this story there are people
who argue this is out of character and
it's kind of true because what they say
is we have to call her and a little bit
of a spoiler here they end up calling
Amanda Waller and the Suicide Squad it's
a little out of character for the bat
family the bat family plays everything
close to the vest right like I mean they
don't air their dirty laundry what would
have happened under any normal
circumstance if this were written by
like Tom King or James Tinian is they
would have taken them back to the
Batcave and they would have been like
you have to answer to Batman like tell
Batman while you're doing what you're
doing what this does is it allows Scott
Liddell to kind of keep that wall it
allows him to sort of keep the the Red
Hood in the outlaws family away from the
Baths family to basically say like they
kind of stand apart except for the most
dire of circumstances it's actually a
pretty smart move I think it's pretty
cool to take that step but if you guys
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the Rob core or hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]